ray kurzweil arbeitet im auftrag von
google daran den tod abzuschaffen und
seine visionen klingen für manche nach
wilden science fiction fantasien aber
tatsächlich hat er einiges auf dem
kasten er hat nicht nur das ja
vorausgesagt in dem ein computer den
weltmeister im schacht besiegen wird
sondern auch den zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion für die nahe zukunft sieht
er die künstliche intelligenz ki auf dem
absoluten siegeszug bereits in wenigen
jahren werden wir seine prognose nach
mit der kg verschmelzen ja sogar selbst
zog heidi werden und damit auch
unsterblich ray kurzweil gilt als
vordenker des trans humanismus und dann
auch dieses hochspannende thema habt ihr
euch bei whatsapp gewünscht und das gibt
es jetzt bei kingston science fiction
bei uns gibt es täglich wissenschafts
videos nur wenn er den kanal achtung
kostenlos abonniert verpasst er kein
video herzlich willkommen das ist
übrigens ein video das zuerst auf dem
englischen kanal von links und science
fiction online gegangen ist kann
passieren
abonieren einfach auf klicks um auf
englisch dann verpasst ihr nichts und
macht zusammen mit mir noch fortschritte
in englisch immer wieder reden wir ja
über künstliche intelligenz cyborgs und
human enhancement also die künstliche
optimierung der menschen und tatsächlich
sorgen viele bereiche wie beispielsweise
die nano gehen und neurotechnologie
dafür dass wir die chance bekommen und
dem entsprechend weiterzuentwickeln
viele sehen das kritisch ganz im
gegenteil aber die anhänger der trans
humanistischen vorstellung der evolution
demnach werden sich die menschen abseits
der biologischen evolution als eine neue
spezies entwickeln demnach sind wir dann
nicht mehr durch den körper oder die
psyche begrenzt es gibt drei mögliche
visionen zum einen designer babys also
ein genetisch neuer mensch das so
genannte phänomen ding macht es möglich
die anhänger erhoffen sich dass
genmanipulationen über generationen
hinweg menschen entstehen lassen könnten
die sich radikal von uns heute
unterscheiden den anhängern nach sollten
eltern selbst bestimmt über die
gestaltung des nachwuchses entscheiden
heißt im klartext kinder mit behinderung
wird es nicht mehr geben der genpool der
kinder
nach dem eigenen willen modifiziert
werden wenn dann erst einmal die
biologie der menschen verändert werden
kann ändert sich danach schritt für
schritt sicherlich auch die kultur
wie gestalte ich mein kind dass es
möglichst nicht diskriminiert wird
mindestens 180 groß weiß und teterow
beim intelligenzquotienten kann man dann
sicher auch später noch mit einem schiff
nach helfen die zweite version geht um
den implantierten neuen menschen cyborgs
nano roboter im menschlichen körper
könnten hybride aus mensch und maschine
widerstandsfähiger machen
viele der menschlichen körperteile wären
demnach nicht mehr biologisch und die
dritte version der digitale neue mensch
auch upload genannt diese vision ist
ziemlich radikal denn demnach wird das
bewusstsein des menschen durch eine
vollständige digitalisierung
transformiert der name dieses prozesses
wholetrain emulation wurde auch ab
loading das gehirn wird dir also quasi
als austausch parat wer definiert mensch
und maschine haben sich dann so
angenähert dass eine digitale kopie von
personen möglich ist ebenso wie ein
download der identität unsere jeweiligen
gehirn software kann auf avatare
überspielt werden nach kurzwahl werden
dann wie gesagt kleine roboter also nano
bots in unserer blutbank unterwegs sein
und krankheiten bekämpfen und es kommt
noch besser
diese vorstellung beinhaltet eine
digitale und sterblichkeit denn
schließlich kann man von diesen so
geschaffenen neuen menschen beliebig
viele backups machen
um das möglich zu machen arbeiten viele
forschungsteams weltweit daran den
körper und seine prozesse aus zu lesen
denn diese müssen ja in humanoiden
robotern nachgebaut werden in dem
sogenannten human brain project das von
der eu finanziert wird soll das
menschliche gehirn simuliert werden am
ende sollen dann künstliche gehirnteile
stück für stück das menschliche gehirn
ersetzen
und man kann sich vorstellen dadurch
könnten tatsächlich krankheiten wie
parkinson bekämpft werden
schließlich soll die natur am ende
überwunden werden ohne leid und tod
genauso wie bei computern eben aber eben
schon angesprochen es gibt auch
reichlich kritik an den transfers
tischen denkweisen zum einen gibt es
existenzielle bedenken ähnlich wie
stephen hawking der das ende der
menschlichen spezies durch die
entwicklung von kari vorausgesagt hat
sieht es eben auch der ki forscher hugo
deges wir werden nicht mithalten können
wir werden nur eine überflüssige spezies
sein wie wir menschen es mit lästigen
fliegen tun so werden die roboter
ausmerzen die risikoforschung sieht die
entwicklung der ki sogar als die
schlimmste bedrohung für die menschheit
neben einem nuklearkrieg andere leute
die den transformers muss kritisieren
bemängeln einen ganz anderen aspekt
nämlich die unwissenschaftlichkeit
dieser denkweise sie hingegen sehen den
menschen als ein komplexes system das
sich eben nicht einfach in zahlencodes
abbilden lässt doch er ist vielleicht
demnächst tatsächlich mehr oder weniger
so kommen wird sind noch viele aspekte
zu klären verhindert werden muss auf
jeden fall dass die menschenwürde in
irgendeiner art und weise verletzt wird
und dafür brauchen wir ausführliche
moralische und ethische diskussionen
genauso wie eindeutige rechtliche
rahmenbedingungen ein riesen thema das
uns sicher noch oft beschäftigen wird
wenn er keins der videos und vor allem
auch nicht in englisch verpassen wollt
dann abonniert klicks um science-fiction
ihr dann verpasst ihr gar nichts und
verbessert zusammen mit mir oder
englisch einfach hier draufklicken
genauso wie darunter wenn er
weitermachen wollte mit dem video
künstliche intelligenz besiegt menschen
keine chance gegen ki bis dann bleibt
dran